i'm here with dr lawrence baker from
stanford medical school and we're going
to talk about what
how about medicare medicare
i think we knew that was going to happen
because we had this picture here already
so what is this a picture of
i think that's a picture of uh lbj
signing and signing the medicare act in
1965 this is the
the time that we passed medicare lyndon
baines johnson lbj this this is this
looks like truman right over here uh i
think so maybe he was there because he i
think was probably old enough by that
point to to be a recipient yeah 65 and
over so so what
you know i think we all have a general
idea of what medicare is that it's kind
of a health care program or an insurance
program for people who are retired but
then it starts to get fuzzy after that
and there are all these details that
confuse most of us
yeah so we talk about medicare in a
bunch of different ways medicare is a
program it's a us government program run
by the federal government so it is run
by the federal government yep and
sometimes it's thrown in with medicaid
how are they different just at a very
high level oh so medicaid is another a
different insurance program run by the
federal government in coordination with
state governments it's medicaid is a
federal and state program medicare is a
federal program medicare is for
folks who are 65 years old and older and
people with disabilities principally
those two groups medicaid is a program
that's aimed at lower income populations
so this is this is older
older people and
disabilities yep this is low-income kind
of a kind of a poverty issue yes more so
let me write that down low
income
and this is primarily retirees
or
the majority the vast majority of people
in there are folks who are there because
they're over 65. okay and we're just
going to focus on medicare and medicare
is federal government medicaid is the
federal and the state governments are in
medicaid because they're always they
sound very similar they sound very
similar yeah i know they're easily
confused at certainly at the name level
really different programs they operate
completely separately
in a few cases there are people who get
access to both of them but they pay
differently they run differently they're
nice but at the federal level they are
still run by the same organization the
the centers for medicaid and medicare or
medicare yeah the department of health
and human services has a a sub-part
called the centers for medicare and
medicaid services
executive branch
oh yeah let me
executive branch of our government
obviously
and then you have the secretary of
health health and human services so
health and human services health and
human services and then within that you
have cms which is the centers for and
you were saying earlier should have two
m's in it yeah it's the centers for
medicare and medicaid services so i
think it's just shorter to have one m
ms okay okay and these they administer
at the federal level both medicare and
medicaid but just to reiterate medicare
is really
mainly a federal thing while medicaid is
both and yeah and they run separately so
you have medicare here
medicare and then you have medicaid here
yeah i see
all right all right so let's dive deep
into
medicare so is it
i guess i guess what is it
so medicare is an insurance program um
it provides insurance coverage for
people who are eligible for it so if
you're age 65 and over or if you have a
permanent disability a couple other
small groups if you have lou gehrig's
disease or or end stage renal disease
kidney failure
then you can get access to medicare too
but those are small populations so if
you're in those groups you're eligible
for medicare medicare will provide you
with insurance that will cover hospital
bills doctor bills
some prescription drugs it'll cover lots
of the medical care and is it you know i
hear these things you know and this this
is the part that i think gets confusing
for everyone is that you start hearing
part a part b part c part d i don't know
if those are all the parts
what what what are those referring to
and are they exactly insurance or are
they something slightly different uh
okay so part so medicare has these four
parts part a part b part c and part d
and you know it can get a little
confusing but we could break it up into
some different pieces so the biggest one
in terms of the number of people who are
in it is what sometimes we call
traditional medicare and that's
what historically is part a and part b
and they you kind of want to take those
two together because they make a package
okay
and we call that maybe traditional
medicare or sometimes people call it
original medicare
standard medicare but okay you know when
they passed the program when they first
did it part a was meant to cover
hospital expenditures and part b was
aimed at doctor cost cost for seeing
physicians um of course those things go
so closely together that nowadays part a
and part b are kind of a pair so you
really rarely would find someone who
only wanted part a or only one right
sometimes you hear those doctor
crossroads outpatient like so it's
hospitals sometimes you hear the word
inpatient means you're you're living
there while they're treating you
outpatient you go visit them for an hour
or two and leave and that's where you
hear those yeah so that's a way of
breaking up the kinds of services that
medicine provides medicare actually gets
a little bit um and it's mix and match
so if
really a medicare part a expenditure is
when a hospital bills medicare for use
of the hospital use of the room use of
the services at the hospital any time a
doctor bills medicare
even if they saw the patient in the
hospital they're going to be a part b
so it is it isn't it isn't strictly
inpatient outpatient it really is much
more along the lines of hospital and
doctor yep okay so i'll i'll maybe put
this in some type of a container way or
something it's not necessarily uh it's
not necessarily outpatient inpatient but
that's maybe one way of yeah it's useful
it is useful to think about that um
outpatient inpatient so and and will it
cover everything that happens are we
including drugs or
okay so drugs is one key issue for the
to the main question the first thing uh
i guess i'd say is that medicare for
traditional medicare is pretty
comprehensive it covers you know most of
the things that people would normally
encounter in their needs around care
does it cover scripting
is one big exception it does not cut so
parts a and part b do not cover
prescription drugs so when when lyndon
johnson was signing this uh if truman
had to get prescribed some drug and if
he was a medicare recipient he would in
1965 he would have to pay that out of
pocket uh yeah so there so the i guess
one caveat i'll note is that if you get
prescription drugs that are administered
to you while you're in the hospital i
see you're staying in the hospital they
give you drugs um that's going to be
generally covered under part a it's when
you're outpatient and you're going home
and then somebody sends you the pharmacy
to pick up
medicare in its original form would not
cover that they would not cover the part
the outpatient prescription drugs um so
that became a problem for some folks and
that has generated changes to the
medicare property since that there have
been there is a part now that covers
that yeah so that's the part d program
is a medicare extension i don't know how
far we want to get a fee we can i'll
write that right here we'll just d for
drugs yeah drugs has the whole story of
prescription drugs and medicare has you
know kind of a lot too but people would
buy additional policies if they had a
and b right they'd buy themselves a
private supplement that might cover
drugs sometimes but now with the new
part d plan maybe um people would buy
that installed and then there's other
stuff there's probably a c right there
there's a c that's coming and get that
to a second but but so a and b
traditional a hospitals b doctors and
what what percent you know with my with
my health insurance there's a copay
every time i visit the doctor it's you
know twenty dollars how does it work
with traditional medicare with parts a
and part b
so if you just have part a and part b
then on the part b side doctors are
covered 80 of the medicare allowable
charges so medicare has a
fee schedule that governs what doctors
can be paid for services and medicare
will cover 80 of that and the patient
pays 20. i see uh
for part a it gets a little more
complicated but there's a a co-payment
that you have to make if you go to the
hospital medicare is going to have a
co-payment of a fixed amount several
hundred dollars uh coming up it's just
not as simple as 80 20. it's not no not
as simple as 80 20. you're going to pay
a co-payment there too um
so you know they're not bad coverage but
there's certainly some costs you can run
up and if you're pretty sick you might
really have a bill that's left in your
aftermath extreme flexibility here you
can see any doctor you want go to any
hospital you want yeah medicare part a
and part b is uh
by to one way of thinking one of the
last bastions of health care as it
exists or health insurance as it existed
in america in 1965 70 75 when there were
really minimal restrictions on what
doctors you could see what hospitals you
could use doctors get lots of discretion
here about the kinds of things they're
gonna the services are gonna provide and
there's not a lot of oversight that you
might see in today's hmos or other kinds
but there are still or maybe i'm wrong
here there still are doctors that won't
take medicare patients so doctors can
elect to be medicare
doctors or not and some doctors i think
decide they have enough business i know
patients from other places and you know
medicare's a plan it's got its rules and
you have to follow the rules and some
people think that medicare doesn't pay
as well as other options they have so
there are a few most of the doctors the
vast majority of doctors in the country
will work with medicare what you're
saying is it is kind of the super
flexible thing if if you do have an
illness uh you can go see multiple
doctors get second opinions you could go
to the specialist on the other side of
the country who uh so it is it is pretty
good that way although you have to pay
you know twenty percent of just the
doctor's visit so it's a pretty so what
what do
are there so what happens you know if
i'm a retiree i don't have a lot of
money and you know i have a major bill
yeah i have a surgery it's 50 000
i know that's more of a hospital
inpatient thing but let's say i have to
you know pay 10 what are there options
so that they don't have to pay that out
of pocket
um
yeah so there's a bunch of things that
go into trying to figure out what the
costs to getting this r and how you
might get coverage for some of those
these other services the main thing that
would be the answer to the question is
um
there are supplemental policies so if
you're a retiree and you've gotten part
a from because you're eligible for that
and you've paid your medicare tax and
you've got part b which you do have to
pay a little bit of money every month
small subsidized but still a premium you
have to pay you might decide in addition
to that to pay for a supplemental
insurance policy which you'd buy from
a private place you know the aarp is one
place that sells these there are others
other folks that sell them you pay an
extra premium for that that's an
additional insurance
plan that you have and that might agree
and or you might have a a method there
to have them cover that 20 percent
co-pay the additional hospitals and
those plans there are some different
varieties of those that cover more or
less generously and of course charge a
higher or lower premium for that
obviously that makes complete sense and
and and do people have to pay any
premium to be in medicare uh to get a
and b both you have to a you generally
don't uh if you pay your medicare tax
for 10 years working you work for 10
years here and you pay your medicare tax
you get part a for free okay but part b
charges a premium uh so you do have to
pay a small monthly well it's like it's
like on the order of like 100
yeah generally it's gone up a little bit
over time something like that it's not
too much and you know maybe 100 or a
little bit more per month which is which
is nothing i mean if you're
if you're 65 or over and you try to get
a private policy you're probably looking
at something like a thousand dollars a
month yeah so this i guess two ways of
thinking about it one this is heavily
subsidized compared to what a person you
know 75 years old would pay for a actual
private insurance policy would be much
much higher than that you know there are
people who look at that 100 a month and
fixed income and social security and
things and you say that's an issue and
so one of the things that's just in the
news the last few weeks is the fact that
this number the number went up a bit uh
social security payments went up a
little bit but less actually than the
medicare so i would say you know i'm
actually decreasing a loss if you're
buying both so there's some people who
will still be worried about that even
though it is heavily subsidized and
looks like a great deal i see and then
finally
so we know a b and then we have a little
bit of d we know it's about covering
drugs what does c do c is that exists c
yes c exists c has been around for 20 or
30 years now
c is a separate choice so when you turn
65 let's say
you can make this choice a little bit
differently sometimes too but when you
turn 65 you might decide to take part a
and part b maybe buy a traditional
supplement maybe add the part d drug
plan on make yourself a package or you
can elect part c and part c is an
alternative
under part c what happens is the the cms
federal government has contracted with
some hmos kaiser blue cross other places
sometimes they've contracted with a few
ppos they've tried other kinds of plans
too mostly it's hmos
and so you have a choice then you can
join kaiser
and
have kaiser be your your medicare plan
you can join the blue cross one
depending on where you are you'll have
different choices of different private
plans that have contracted uh and you
can do that the federal government will
then pay a bunch of your premium to them
so you'll get covered by the by the
private plan with the federal government
covering your costs they might ask you
to pay some additional premium you're
going to have to pay your part b
equivalent already so you got to pay
that amount but then you might have to
pay a little bit extra i see and then
you'll get access to what services that
has and so some for some people that's
attractive because though the
co-payments and deductibles will be
lower you'll often have more like the 10
copay right um you might have access to
some prescription drug coverage
automatically built in there sometimes
those cover some vision and other things
which might be nice so this is so
one or two plans i could get this rust
80 coverage well i i can't make that
rule because hospitals it could be
different but you get this kind of
flexible thing but you have a pretty
significant co-pay the 20 patient i
could get supplemental insurance for me
to cover some of that right over there
or i can do parts is there a name for
parts you met part c these days is
called medicare advantage so the plans
in part c are called medicare advantage
plans and so you know which is really
just medicare
paying subsidizing me to get private
insurance
right from some plans that have agreed
to work with medicare patients and you
know they've agreed they they do there's
various checking up on them so they
agree to make to basically cover
everything that a and b would cover you
know so you're not going to get skimped
on and what do most people do they go a
and b the traditional route or they go
to the c route so historically the vast
majority of people have gone a and b
route it changes kind of goes up and
down over time depending on various
factors but you know over the over a
historical average would be something
like 80 85 90 percent in a uh and maybe
20 50 10 and b and c depending on which
year you're looking at over the last 15
years right and we could probably do a
whole series of videos on it but what is
when did d come about it wasn't part of
the original d is not part of the
original d comes about in the early
2000s uh under george bush george w bush
um and what we heard about i think it
was like 2003 i think it was i think
that's probably about right and you know
the issue there was there's a lot of a
lot of folks who are having trouble
getting their outpatient drugs covered
in there
so this is a plan this is another
part of medicare you can elect to buy
this you normally would think about this
if you've got a and b and you want to
get outpatient drugs covered you think
about a d plan part d is
run by the federal government kind of
the way that c is they they pay up they
subsidize and they pay a premium to
uh
the private plans that cover drugs and
then i see the person at least they
organize the market and the person then
pays also some premium together so a
private private a private entity will
handle the actual reimbursements for the
drugs but medicare will pay them yeah so
you know the way to think about it is
just a bunch of private entities with
funds flows coming in you know partly
from the person partly from medicare to
buy these okay so
and so you and you would pay uh who do
you pay your money to you pay it to
medicare you pay to these uh these
oh
um
i
actually don't yeah yeah well i guess
yeah it works out the same way
one way or the other but you're paying
this is optional a retiree or someone
over 65 would pay money to essentially
get a drug plan
subsidized yes okay yes cool cool well
no this is actually you know i'm trying
to think about subsidies but
you know there's some there's some
interesting questions about the extent
to be able to participate in in a drug
plan i mean they are subsidized and the
federal government is kicking a bunch of
money in but it's uh you know how
exactly the economics of these plans
works out is an interesting discussion
right right we could make a ton of
videos no this is super helpful because
i think you know frankly i didn't know
about the differences right right here
before
about 15 minutes ago
well thanks a bunch